[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
starting with my routine announcement
i'm
welcoming you to the colloquium i'm
scott ostwald creative director of the
mit education arcade
um i want to welcome you to tonight's
colloquium and just
again to go over the ground rules with
zoom we run this as a webinar which
means
that the
members of the cms graduate program and
faculty are on as panelists just so that
they can participate
in the conversation after the
presentation if we recognize you as
somebody from
the mit community we'll try to promote
you to panelists as well
if you remain a guest you're also
welcome to participate we just
ask you to ask questions in the q a
um but you're more than welcome to
be here this week and every week for the
colloquium um
with that i will turn things over to
professor vivek bald who's going to
actually introduce
tonight's colloquium thank you scott
um well it's it's really a pleasure to
be able to
to welcome mauricio cardero to the
colloquium it's been a pleasure to
to have mauricio as part of the cms
community for the last few years and
just a little about mauricio he has
worked in the arts and underground scene
since the 1980s
he established the fanzine caution and
served as the education
coordinator and program director at the
institute of contemporary art
in boston in france he opened his own
art gallery in tour
returning to the us he served as
executive director at the revolving
museum
and was also a founding director of mill
number five
an indoor victorian streetscape which
i'd like to hear a bit more about in the
q a
cordero now teaches comics primarily and
is a part-time lecturer at
mit he is currently teaching making
comics and sequential art
and lecturing in the visual story
graphic novel
uh his work has been published in double
nickels forever
dollars and cents mit's grad x comic
series
and the fashion institute of
technologies black stories matter
border x a crisis in graphic detail is
available at all major online retailers
and through the website
borderx.com and we're going to hear
about border x
okay
oh i i think i've lost audio
you can hear me great okay so i'm just
gonna let this roll
um
hi i'm mauricio cordero i'm a lecturer
at mit i teach a course on comics
production
i'm also the founder and the editor of
border x today i'll be in conversation
with
professor james parady as well as
professor warren binford who is the
president
and the founder of project amplify
we'll also hear from several of the
artists who contributed
to this volume and first
we'll hear a special message from
someone whose actions
really inspired me to take action
that's senator jeffrey merkley from
oregon welcome to today's presentation
of the border x project
morgan senator jeff merkley and the
topic is one
i'm personally very invested in
two years ago just days after attorney
general jeff sessions announced the
administration's zero
tolerance policy which criminalized
refugees and purposefully
traumatized children for fleeing
persecution
and unspeakable violence i flew down to
the border
to see the situation for myself i walked
through a customs and border protection
patrol station
where i saw rows of chain link cages
filled
with young children i stopped in front
of one
where young boys were lining up by
height the youngest in front
he was just knee-high to a grasshopper
maybe four years old
at most i couldn't believe what i saw in
that facility
i could not believe that our government
the u s government
was deliberately traumatizing children
ripping them out of their parents arms
to discourage refugee families from
seeking safe harbor
in the united states it still haunts me
today it should haunt every american
i also went to visit another facility
where i'd heard that hundreds of boys
perhaps as many as a thousand were being
held who had been separated from their
parents
i couldn't imagine a thousand boys
incarcerated in that former walmart and
i couldn't imagine
the experiences they'd gone through at
the hands of our government
i wanted to find out the details the
on-site manager agreed to come outside
and talk to me
but instead he called the police to have
me escorted
off the police off the property
well when he did that millions of
americans
were watching on facebook live and those
americans wondered just as i was
wondering
what is our government hiding behind
those locked doors
never before would i have believed that
our government
the united states of america would
plunge ahead with a strategy of
traumatizing children
deliberately but it was real
by the end of the year more than fifteen
thousand refugee children were held in
camps across
our nation today at this moment our
american government has still been
unable to reunite more than
600 of them with their parents
and all of those children all those many
thousands
still have to live with the trauma of
their experiences
inflicted at the hands of our government
the child separation was only the
beginning of the trump administration's
war on refugees as we all know there
were many more pieces that policy
but it's up to us now with trump heading
out the door
to confront the pain and suffering to do
all we can to remedy the pain
and suffering of those children and do
all we can to restore
fairness and justice to the immigration
system
we need to ensure that policies like
child separation never
ever happen again i know that
that's why many of you have come to this
gathering today
thank you thank you for working to
understand the cruelty unleashing our
southern border
and how we can work together to end it
working together let's relight lady
liberty's
torch
why don't you say something about uh
what got you uh you know thinking about
uh comics and borders the origin was
really anger
and rage uh that i was feeling and
i i hadn't felt this angry since i was a
teenager
you know rebelling against reagan and
bush and
living growing up in dc around politics
i mean that was
or meat and potatoes down there we
thought about
politics all the time even as a high
school student and um
you know back then the rage was directed
uh
towards music so i realized that you
know
if i was going to bring
any sort of substantial record or
evidence of my rebellion it had to be in
the form of a comic book
and so i started to directly contact a
few friends and say you know hey what do
you think about this and and the
response was overwhelmingly positive but
i was just
curious if there was some set of
episodes or something that uh
set this off i think the the first
incident was senator jeff merkley uh
trying to
get into the detention camp and being
turned away
and it wasn't at all what he said on
camera
as he was turned away it was the absence
of footage from inside the border camp
seeing how much the political structure
in our government
had caved into this new doctrine
that was very i feel racist
uh very anti-asylum
these are people who are in most cases
fleeing
a situation that is unlivable untenable
for them in their families and they're
trying to make a better life
but as we know the person who
is in the white house right now referred
to them as rapists and murderers and
drug dealers
not having a view inside the camps
concerned me knowing that just about
everything that comes out of that
person's mouth is
either projection or just a lie
my tweets weren't going anywhere you
know and certainly didn't
satisfy that rage and so
you know that diy punk rock spirit
came back to me and i said well i've got
to make all this concrete
and found out about project amplify who
published testimony of migrants that
were presented
in flores versus bar the
construction of artistic work requires a
kind of
a suspension of rage and
some of the uh the emotions that might
lead
to starting it uh so how did that work
well
when i opened up the project to the
world at large um i realized i was
getting a lot of rage back
and that's when i installed a ban
on the word trump and that is where the
rage turned
into productivity you know it started
with rage
and then quickly became compassion and
then
i realized i had to steer the ship you
can only
raise so much in a piece before it
becomes too literal
to be art and it becomes a
form of almost propaganda or something
like that
there there's this long history of
americans
trying to figure out uh how they're
going to
exist in a world that is way more
complicated than
some may understand
uh as far as indigenous uh there are
hundreds of indigenous people on every
continent
of the every continent of the of of the
globe
and uh this is one focus
that you have on this particular
location but it it sort of stands
does it not for uh uh you know a kind of
universal problem
that has to do with borders absolutely
and
at the very beginning i made the
decision to include science fiction
and fiction um as one of the sections
that we would have in the
the final work to get to the universal
um truths in this struggle
we we need fiction we need science
fiction we need allegories
that go beyond the headlines and beyond
this moment
um and even beyond this planet um
and so i i really enjoyed um
curating that section and finding the
artists it was
um wonderful to get so many different um
points of view looking inward um and
modalities you know science fiction uh
straight documentary
uh some reportage so maybe uh and
personally
since you're you're bridging on some of
these
these questions uh maybe say a little
more about the process of
making this how does a person uh
decide and then go about making a
collection like this because yeah
well when you get to the point where the
rage outweighs common sense
i think that's that's where you get
started i found myself
kind of alone at the beginning and then
people did step up
um as the project uh grew um
so i guess the the first step is uh
deciding
you're going to do it and defining it
and scale it to what your
abilities are or
um the way i did it was uh
naively scaling it way above my
abilities and having
to grow into those abilities um
so you know i have experience in
producing comics and putting them
together
i know all the tech specs etc um
but there's a much greater learning
curve um
in terms of hurting 70 contributors
and these contributors sometimes uh i
mean a comic is
is not always done just by a single
author
and generally it's it's done by there's
an anchor there's a
a colorist there's someone who deals
with the
uh the actual narratives the bubbles and
all the things that so how did that all
work out did
did most of these uh get done by i i
noticed that uh
almost all of them have multiple
multiple uh
constructors there are multiple people
involved
right well that was uh part of
what uh took a lot of
legwork at the beginning was playing
matchmaker
now there were people that came uh
with a team and and were ready to go uh
a few in a few cases uh there was
existing
work that we could just take and reprint
where the artist had all the rights to
uh reprint so
that happened but i did play matchmaker
and uh really took time to read scripts
pass them along to penciller or artists
and um you know at that point we
determined whether the artist would take
on the entire project or if
i had to go out and find a letter or
colorist um so really uh
trying to find um what a comfortable
or doable workload was for each
participant yeah there were a few um
people that were just really helpful
royal torres for example
um was one person who stepped up and
helped a lot with the editing
and he got a lot of teams together found
a lot of uh
tied up a lot of loose ends uh i'm i'm
curious about the
organization which i i think is very
very effective uh but you you have the
exhibits
which are sort of uh you know uh
reviews interviews and things of that
sort that were
captured these are testimonials
uh but then you have the response and
you have the
context and then ruminations and then
the series of posters
so i'm just curious about that that
collection which i think is a rich
variety of uh possibilities for
this this form as the work began to
arrive i saw a pattern
emerge and the pattern strengthened over
time
into what seemed like four good sections
um for the book
the four sections are the exhibits the
response the context
and ruminations so i felt that
the factual and most heart-wrenching
work should appear at the beginning
of the book to establish uh what what
we're talking about when we say
migrant crisis these the exhibits are
based on verbatim transcripts
of migrant experiences in the detention
camp
and these testimonies were presented to
the supreme court
in ongoing floors versus bar case
to mitigate the just devastating
nature of these testimonies i chose to
to highlight agents and agencies that
are
working to create hope uh
by aiding migrants in
you know in the field and so the
response section
uh collects a few of those stories
then the context uh section collects
personal reflections and historic
accounts
uh to try to offer a broad contextual
background
uh for the the volume the last section
the ruminations offers fiction
allegory metaphor and adaptation
to get at some of the underlying themes
and
universal truths that we can find in the
crisis
and closing out the volume there's a a
small section of
posters that were created especially
for the collection in the vein of sort
of works progress administration
uh sort of war era posters do you have
any kind of expectations
for the impact of a piece of work like
this
or is there is it kind of more diffuse
kind of cultural just uh awareness or
how do you how do you think about impact
one impact i'd hope for
is precisely what we're talking about
today
sharing this model with the public in
hopes of inspiring the replication
for other social causes
another is to create a graphic history
of this
moment so that we don't forget these
atrocities that are being carried out in
the name of the us
also bearing witness to the suffering
and torment endured by the subjects
in this book who've they've got so much
to offer
uh or society yet they're treated like
criminals
for seeking a better life asylum is not
a crime
crossing the border illegally is a
misdemeanor yet it
seems like they're being punished for a
felony or some other serious crime
finally we set out to to help a
nonprofit
and the one we decided on the south
texas human
rights center is a really good example
of an organization with an extremely
modest budget
and they're creating a real benefit to
society
and uh the funds we've collected
and the proceeds that we continue to
generate
uh have gone to help them carry out
their mission
and we'll hear a bit more about the
south texas human rights center later on
in the presentation
how does distribution work and things of
that sort the question
about distribution format came up
immediately
should i try to find a publisher and
potentially wait
years to see any sort of result
or take a risk and self-publish and rely
mostly on word of mouth i
chose the latter and despite many
difficulties
delays complications some of them due to
covid
in the end i think it was the best
choice
by using a print on demand service we
had a lower risk
than vanity printing and we were able to
get the volume into production
eight months after the start of the
project so
that's eight months to contact all the
contributors
create the content edit design layout
and get it to print and distribution
also by serving as the publisher we
can continue to generate profit which
goes to
fund the south texas human rights center
and the title
is currently being distributed worldwide
so
it's available for about the same cost
as buying it here in the us
so i'd say the benefits are similar to
the traditional
publishing route but with a much higher
revenue stream
and lower risks it gives
it sort of gives a new meaning to public
art
you know the creation of uh and
collaborating
together to try to address issues that
uh
are really outstanding and urgent
and we need more of this not less
uh this is a pioneering effort i would
say
uh just from what i know about comics so
you've kind of invented a new process
uh it's it's it's a
it's a really brilliant project so i
just thank you
yeah very very glad that it happened and
you know
i hope i hope you continue
let's get started so
warren can you tell me a little bit
about
the the origin of project amplify
um how it got started why it got started
when it got started and what the mission
is
yes project amplifier was started in the
summer
of 2019 after
uh approximately a dozen of us left the
clint border patrol facility where we
had discovered
over 350 children being kept in a
windowless warehouse a loading dock
jail cells and temps in the desert the
children were hungry they were filthy
they had been severely neglected
there was no one supervising them they
were sleeping on concrete floors
concrete blocks next to open toilets uh
they had been taken away from you know
family members
and uh and were basically left alone to
take care of each other
there was widespread illness there was a
flu and respiratory illness that was
going around
there was a lice infestation and we went
to the public
about what we had discovered because the
situation had gotten
so dangerous and so extreme under under
president trump's administration
uh in the year leading up to that summer
of
2019 at least seven children had died
in government custody or shortly after
they had been released from government
custody and we were afraid that more
children were going to die
the president denounced it as fake news
said that our accounts were grossly
exaggerated um
he and vice president uh pence assured
that the children were well taken care
of which was not true
and they put vice president pence both
on the sunday talking head shows and
then
air force two and flew him down to texas
where
he toured another facility they dressed
the children and government issued
brightly colored sweatsuits and then
have the children pose for the camera
and wave and give a thumbs up that they
were being well taken care of
and we realized that there was a false
counter narrative that was being
advanced at the highest levels of
government and wondered how it was that
we
could counter that narrative so that
these children's experiences and their
histories
were not erased and we decided to
create a website and post all of the
publicly available testimonies of the
children on that website so that any
member of the public who wanted to
inform themselves
could go and read the children's
accounts and
um and discover for themselves what the
truth was what the children said
in their own words and then we called
out to
artists and writers and musicians and
everyday americans and asked them to
read the children's accounts and find
ways to amplify their voices
what was different in 2019 than previous
years
yeah so i started visiting the camps in
2017.
you know sometimes children are in cages
and sometimes they're in jail cells so
it's important
for people to understand that um there
are many facilities in which these
children are being kept
and none of them that i visited are
appropriate for children
and what was different about what
happened in the last four years
is the number of children who are being
held the length of time in which they
were being held
the number of children who were being
removed from their families including
their parents
and the um the level of abuse they were
experiencing
and the number of deaths prior to the
children
who died um in in 2018 and 2019
that no child had died in
you know no you know immigrant child you
know our child immigration had died in
government custody
in almost a decade and we saw
approximately seven children that we
know
of you know there may have been more but
we know seven children
who had died um in the year leading up
to our visit to clint in june
2019. so that's what we were saying
conditioned so bad
that children were literally dying and
um
and it was you know the last year alone
in 2019
there were approximately uh 69
000 children who have been detained by
the us government and
that was a significantly increased
number from
what we've seen in years past so are
they committing a crime
by crossing the board it depends when
someone comes to united states for the
purpose of claiming asylum
they are not required to have
documentation so people who are coming
to the united states
to claim asylum for that purpose are not
committing a crime they have the right
to do that
under u.s law they have the right to do
that under
international law however if someone is
coming to the united states
for the purpose of for example getting a
job um
they are committing a crime and that
crime is a misdemeanor it's the
equivalent
of playing your radio too loud or you
make music too loud
and so what that means is when the trump
administration
implemented the zero tolerance policy
and said we're going to take
children away from anybody who crosses
the border
um you know without consideration of
a you know whether or not they're coming
for asylum
they were essentially violating the law
and then when they
took children away from people who
weren't here for planning asylum but for
jobs literally they were taking their
children away from a misdemeanor that
was the equivalent of playing their
music too loud starting in january 2019
they started to
implement what's called the migrant
protection protocols
um also known as remain in mexico and
um and many of the children and families
that normally would be in the united
states while their asylum things are
being heard
are being sent to these very dangerous
border towns in mexico
where that are controlled by gangs that
are controlled by cartels where there's
a lot of human trafficking remember that
mexico is one of the lead source
countries for human trafficking in
america
and rather than keep the children in the
united states
with their family their parents other
loved ones they're sending them to these
really dangerous border towns
and then keeping them there for what
could be a two
three four five year process in march
2020 the trump administration basically
started to block all arrivals to the
united states
um and blamed it on copenhagen which is
so
ironic because this administration
doesn't recognize you know the severity
or danger of covid the hundreds of
children that we do know about
are actually being kept in black box
locations
uh such as hotels and so we're having a
really hard time
tracking those children is it worse you
know being in a tent in mexico with your
parents for several years
you know or what's likely to be you know
several years or is it worse to be
separated from your parents for you know
89 days which is the average was the
average
under the trump administration until
recently and
and captain border patrol facilities you
know or a
walmart um but then reunited with your
family after that
and um and i guess where i come down
is that both of these are horrible and
neither one of them
is acceptable and what we really need to
do
is under a new administration and with a
new congress
we need to create legal protections to
make sure
that the brutality that children have
been subjected to
under this administration never happens
again
and i've already spoken with uh senator
mercury's office
about working together to uh
you know draft legislation that makes
sure that this never happens again we
need to get to the root problem part of
the root problem is is trying to support
security in the children's home
countries so that they don't need to
migrate
but for those who do need to migrate to
make sure that they are
treated humanely throughout the asylum
process
uh we also you know uh michael
bohanek of human rights watch and i also
are um
working on a policy piece that describes
how to undo all of the damage that's
been done by the trump administration
and we hope to have that published in
january and i mean we're already seeing
such a severe drop
in students foreign students coming to
the united states to study
and it's a huge brain drain frankly that
that's something that
that you you know this you work at mit
you know this is something that we've
relied on for years
which is you know an open academy
globally
so that people could come here and there
could be a vibrant exchange of ideas
this is what the whole fulbright program
is is about and so they they really are
um you know creating a tremendous um
impediment to enrichment of america by
having
you know an open flow of global ideas
and global talent
so you know what we know is that
when you isolate people
they go quite mad you know we see this
with the unabomber we see
this with other isolationists that
human beings are inherently
social creatures who need interaction
with others we need interactions in
order to
be exposed to fresh ideas we need
interaction with others
in order to inspire creativity we need
to not lock ourselves up
in a basement for so many reasons
i mean literally we're already going
quite mad just
you know in in the months that we've
been in lockdown
and in the months that we've tried to
you know
change to a closed society i mean you
look at what's happening as we
create these echo chambers and how
insane family members are
that we've talked to for years but now
that we are starting to close ourselves
off and
not engage with people who have
different ideas then then we have
it has become so unhealthy and so toxic
that i think it's it gives us a vision
of what life would be like in the united
states if we continue to further isolate
ourselves
both as a country and as different
groups within the country who have
political ideas that might not be
consistent with others
why or how can art help yeah
so it's so interesting because i'm not
an artist i'm not particularly creative
and yet i can look at a work of art
and feel it resonate in
every pore of my being there are times
when i can't
read another sad story and yet i can
look at a picture
and be completely open and absorb the
story
or the image that that art conveys
artists can simply
create an image create a sound
tell a story and
that can silence the noise
and allow a truth to be known and and i
appreciate the courage that they have to
do things like read the stories
of the you know read the declarations
the testimonies
of the children who have been abused at
the border allow
that trauma into their being and to
transform
the child's trauma through secondary
exposure trauma of the artists
in order to help get the children
stories out is
uh the news media in particular
helping the situation at the border
so uh so i have to say that i think that
the news media
has really really helped us with certain
getting the truth out about certain
stories so
the separation of children from their
parents and making sure that the public
knew
about children who were being abused in
the clinton border patrol facility and
neglected down there
the the media has really disappointed me
as far as
um you know educating the public about
what was going on with the children who
were being sent to mexico who are not
mexican and you know including many who
don't speak spanish
i wish that the media understood better
that the
children in mexico are in constructive
us custody
because they have asylum hearings
pending
you know that they are asylum and you
know the refugees basically and
and that the 89 of them have
families or other loved ones in the
united states who can keep
take care of them in regular homes and
send them to schools
while their asylum claims are being
heard and instead they're being kept
intense and
you know cartel controlled areas
um you know two of the children that a
colleague of mine uh and and his team
interviewed um they were killed
before the interviewers playing had even
left the ground
you know in tijuana and so these
children's lives are at risk
they're they're not receiving access to
education which they have a right to
and um there is the likelihood that they
will remain there
for years you know the entire world has
recognized that children have a right to
all these things that children have a
right to family integrity
that children have a right to be in a
safe and secure environment that they
have a right
to to education and um and that they
have a right to
um you know safety uh you know from
prosecution and to be free of abuse and
neglect
and whether you're talking about the u.s
facilities in the united states that i
visited
or whether you talk about you know the
camps and other facilities where
children are being sent by the us
government
um to mexico none of these
meet the children's rights that have
been recognized under the un convention
on the rights of child which has been
ratified
by every every country in the world but
one
the people who have seen
you know who have seen border x and have
seen some of the other
projects have expressed
so much appreciation
and such a strong emotional response
to these different projects and they're
so appreciative of all the artists who
have contributed to
them i think that they have played a key
role
in helping to motivate people to get out
the vote
and to call for a change in leadership i
think
that you know the mistreatment
of children and migration and their
families has been identified
as a key issue that to
you know suburban women in in
in swing states and i think that to the
extent
that those women those voters
find out about and come to understand
what's been done to these children and
their families that it can have a
dispositive
impact on this election so
every artist every musician every writer
everyone who has put up the children's
one of the children's quotes
on long sign people who have done street
art
in philadelphia and elsewhere the sky
riders who have sent messages
you know in the skies behind their
planes um
during major public events i think all
of these people
should know that at best they may have
contributed
to change the outcome of this election
and in doing so change in the course of
history
they have helped to make sure that there
is an accurate history
of what was done to these children and
in doing so they have
not only honored our nation in making
sure that we understand what we've done
and you know and what we have
tragically allowed to happen um
but that these children's identities and
experiences
are honored and amplified i just
appreciate so much
the role that comics have played and the
comics artists have played
when i first reached out and asked
the public to do this i did not
imagine the overwhelming support that
we've seen
from comics artists you know from south
park to border rex
to the illustration the children's book
and i am so grateful to all of you
for contributing your your talents so
thank you so much for amplifying their
voices
and thank you so much um when i started
border x
i i had not yet heard of project amplify
it was really the the
the linchpin that that
brought a lot of people in that couldn't
commit to longer pieces
and it really helped us get those first
few comics that then
grew out the rest of the project so
thank you so much for all your work
with project amplify and everything else
that you're doing
oh thank you mauricio i appreciate you
so much you're welcome
hello this is eddie canales i'm the
director of the south texas human rights
center
that is located in brooks county and
falfurias
is the county seat of brooks county
brooks county has demonstrated to be
over the last 10 years the apex of
migrant deaths
and we have a humanitarian crisis of
of migrant bodies and skeletal remains
being
recovered in brooks county this year
it has been uh today there's been 30
32 bodies that have been and scheduled
remains that have been recovered
this demonstrates a humanitarian crisis
that exists on the u.s mexico border
and in in that note that crisis
uh is is demonstrated by the
border x comic book anthology a comic
book form
and has been well received by a lot of
my
colleague members of our organization
uh individuals and our universities
ngos that are reviewing and taking
the anthology and using it in their
classroom
and using it to educate the community
and also
decision makers and stakeholders without
border x
we would not have the tool that uh that
has been developed by
maurizio cordero and his colleagues in
terms of highlighting
the crisis that exists at the border and
the different issues that
that are are very prevalent thank you
very much
for your attention on this short video
uh
if you need any questions call
or look at the south texas human rights
center facebook page and our website
thank you very much hi my name is david
lasky
i am a graphic novelist i've been
making graphic novels in comics for
about 30 years
for border x i adapted the
testimony of a 15 year old girl
who was detained seeking
entrance into the u.s and placed
in a
giant cage with many other
children at the clint border facility
near el paso texas in one page
i tried to give a visual
look at her experience and
amplify her voice in this way
because i am outraged
that the us is
separating children and parents
putting children in cages and
then not able to reunite them with
parents it's
disgusting and
as an artist you know i wanted
something i could do besides just
signing internet petitions
so this was a way to use my skills to
try to help
and i hope it will make a difference for
children like this girl who just want a
better life
in our country my name is brian delay
i teach the history of the u.s mexican
borderlands at uc berkeley
and i had the good pleasure of meeting
mauricio cordero
last year in 2019 at stanford university
where i was a fellow
and we got to talking about our shared
love of comic books um
i been a big comic book fan my whole
life
and managed to come book store for a few
years before i went to graduate school
uh and he mentioned this remarkable
exciting project that he had
been spearheading border x to raise
awareness and
and and raise money for immigrant rights
on the border
uh and he invited me to think about
whether or not i might be able to come
up with some kind of a
of a short piece based in history
and after thinking about it for a while
i decided that it would be interesting
to write
a short script about a remarkable
mexican figure he was a general and a
scientist named manuel
mier itaran and in the early 1830s he
tried to convince
his superiors in the mexican government
that something terrible was about to
happen in texas
that the colonists that the country had
invited into texas were
going to rebel and that the country that
mexico was going to lose texas forever
and he failed he failed to convince them
to take the action that they needed
and he killed himself so it
seemed like um a relevant story for
thinking about the crisis on the border
today
because in manuel mier itaran's time it
was an immigration crisis
it's just that the immigration crisis
was coming from the united states
so i came up with the script and uh to
my
um great delight uh uh
mauricio agreed to do the artwork
himself
and so the finished product is the
piece in border x called texas killed
him
and it was a a great experience working
with mauricio and being part of this
wonderful collection
david martin davies and i'm ivet
benavidez
we are proud to have contributed our
journalism to
border x a crisis in graphic detail
in my story water stations save lives
consuela terra's incredible artwork
brought to life
the story that i found in south texas
where eddie canales
founder of the south texas human rights
center builds and maintains water
stations in the desert
without them many more immigrants would
die of thirst
kittens in cages is my story which
documents how children are forced to
represent themselves
in u.s immigration court and the utter
lack of concern for their safety
and their lives chris dorae's artwork
captures the array of emotions that i
experienced while covering the story
without a doubt more people need to see
these graphic journalism stories
and gain a better understanding of the
atrocities that are happening
on america's southern border many thanks
to mauricio cordero for spearheading
this ambitious project
and making it a reality
hi i'm samantha stevenson and i'm one of
the contributors to the border x
comics anthology it was important to me
to be part of this project
as an immigrant i wanted to help in
some way and this gave me the
opportunity
to to help in raising money for the
south texas human rights center
and also to help raise awareness about
what's happening at the border
um i think for myself sometimes it's
um to even acknowledge
the what's happening can be so deeply
and profoundly distressing
um that sometimes we just turn away
because
we just don't know what to do it's
i'm not a lawyer i'm not a politician
i'm an artist and musician
so to be given this opportunity to
actually contribute
in some way to help was just
just great and the process of um
reading the declarations was deeply
disturbing
to really see what is happening there
and
uh i think it's important that art
whether it be the performance arts the
visual arts
um the creative process
to be able to bring these things to
light is is very powerful
also i think it's it's really
interesting to have it as a comics
anthology
because it's it's something that you can
hold in your hand
you can read in the quiet of you
wherever
it is that you are it's not a news
report
in someone else's voice the barrage of
words
being thrown at you and i find that
perhaps
there's a certain connection that can
happen there
that can be pretty pretty powerful
hi this is donna barr and i'm speaking
for
mauricio cardera's project his border x
that will help support uh actions
against the
treatment of asylum seekers in
the united states and on our borders and
i'm the author of the desert beach and
stints and i've done a lot of work in
comics many
projects over the years and i thought
this was a very worthwhile project
um my one page that i did uh has to do
with the fact that
we are well on our way into the same
processes used
as in nazi germany in the treatment of
asylum seekers or people of color
or women or anybody else uh it's the
same processes
and so that's what i wanted to emphasize
in
my page that i did for border x
comics are a really good medium for
activism
because you can take very complex ideas
boil them down and express them simply
and directly and concisely
using words and images for example i
think about
uh those little cards that are sometimes
in restaurants or in posters about what
to do when someone's choking
there isn't even language but they're
essentially a comic that is expressing
something very complex
simply to a wide audience the same is
true with
activism and comics where you're trying
to get an idea across
to an audience a variety of ages a
variety of languages
and this medium allows you to do that it
also allows you to disseminate the
information
electronically it can you could do it on
in paper
and
i think that comics really taps into
the visual language that people are used
to
and can consume easily
when i first approached the safe passive
project the idea for this comic
thought it was going to be about their
clients coming to america
so i set up a roundtable interview with
five of their lawyers and over the
course of those interviews we identified
specific topics that would be important
to their clients
had of course nothing to do with them
coming to america they already
knew about that what they didn't know
was what is a pro bono lawyer why should
i trust a pro bono lawyer
what do i do if i get suspended from
school what do i do if i get a ticket
uh very specific questions very specific
concerns for their client base
after i had all those interviews i had
them transcribed
then i read over them and using
highlighters highlighted the things that
i thought would be the most important
once i took all of those highlighted
things
i boiled them down into a comic script
into a thumbnail then i handed them off
to peter cupper who was
the person who drew the comic and then
together we
made the comic this comic was then
disseminated
within courthouses to sister
organizations
across the united states and could be
available digitally and in comic book
form
i think what border x is doing is such a
great example of comics and activism
because there was an idea i want to help
immigrants there was an
organization that um was identified to
raise money for then the word went out
within the comics community who can help
me do this comic
many people myself included
wanted to contribute and then you have
all these stories and of course
stories are the building blocks for
empathy and without empathy we can't
really move forward
hi i'm tom hart i'm the executive
director of the sequential artists
workshop
we're a grassroots comics organization
we're online and
in person in gainesville florida we
teach comics and
support any um
any literacy and other uh projects in
the medium
i've never been a very good activist i'm
afraid
i've always half of me has always wished
i could be a better activist
but the other half of me always
stays in the art world i became an
artist
because i believe in
what people have to express i believe in
something really
innate and beautiful and interesting
about the complexity
of people i believe in what people
are allowed
to do i believe i believe that when
people are allowed to be themselves
allowed to flourish when they have
the safety and the permission
and the guidance and some inspiration
that they do most the most profound
interesting beautiful things
and so my story in border x was um
strange
it was not reportage it was not a
documentary it was not
trying to show um some stories that
haven't been already seen
it was trying to
investigate some of the emotions and
some of the back story
all of my stories have been fueled by
rage
rage that this that people aren't
treated like people
mostly that people aren't treated like
they are something valuable that they
have something valuable to contribute
i've always believed that people do
and that people empowered by their
community by their broader world
um will
shine beautiful things provide beautiful
things
create beautiful things and the the
constant destruction of people's spirits
and their physical bodies is
the biggest harm anyone can do
and we do it constantly as a culture
and so my story is as strange as they
are the one in border x as
wild as it is is
fueled by that rage and that belief
that we should be providing for each
other
um so we're gonna uh as scott
mentioned there is a q a um
that that folks who are uh attendees
from outside
mit can can write their questions into
and
um and we'll be opening up to questions
from everyone on screen right now first
um
i wanted to just step in
and and um ask a question to to start
things off mauricio
um and that is i you know i'm thinking
about the the posters that
were um uh that you
showed early on in this presentation
from
um the dc punk rock scene that you were
connected to
and particularly the poster the rock
against reagan
poster that was a series of shows that
happened all over the
the country really in different punk
rock scenes
um and um
i really have two questions connected to
that one is
just um about what you
um what you learned and what you have
sort of brought forward as an artist
from from those origins within
um the dc punk scene which was a
particularly politically engaged scene
you know compared to others across the
country
and the other is actually on a broader
political level thinking about reagan
and thinking about what
um the the kind of activism that
um so many were involved in at that
moment
um to tie that to
the border crisis right now because you
know i think
sometimes um what gets lost in press
accounts is
is the the historical depth of you know
why people are fleeing from central
america
um to cross the border which of course
does
date back to the reagan era so i was
wondering if you could
you know the two very different
questions from looking at that same
poster but
um if you could talk about those to
start off
sure um so i was lucky enough to grow up
uh in the punk scene and um
like you said it was not like um
the scene in london or new york or
anywhere else it was not concerned with
fashion it wasn't about having spiky
jackets and you know green hair or
anything like that
it was really about politics and
how young people can resist
and really rage against politics and try
to channel that
into uh creativity and art um
so you know early on uh at one show
i was like 14 15
uh just standing by the stage and uh ian
mckay
and john stab and uh
i believe it was henry rollins walked up
to me and asked me if i was
you know so and so i don't remember what
the name was and i was like no but
you are in you know henry and john stab
and they were that those were my idols
and to have them actually just
be so approachable sort of shaped
my attitude towards art and music i i
i wanted to
[Music]
patronize art artists who are
approachable
and sort of down to earth um and also i
i i don't have a problem with going up
to
someone i admire and asking them for
something you know especially when it's
for a larger cause
um wow uh reagan
um so we did have these wonderful
shows uh right there on the mall
uh at first they were rock against
reagan um
then rock against bush
and so every year around the 4th of july
or on the 4th of july
it was sort of a counter concert
almost like the chicago dnc where the
mc5
played outside to sort of counter what
was going on inside
um and those were those were quite
uh formative and informative um
concerts and in and productions i uh
you know there would be tons of flyers
given out but also
leaflets um i first learned about the
the genocide in
guatemala through a millions of dead
cops
uh album mdc um they had an insert that
detailed uh the atrocities and some of
the most
um graphic uh disturbing photos that i'd
ever seen um things that were just not
being
uh promoted in in the press
uh for obvious reasons i mean they're
gruesome photos um
and so that's sort of
blunt honesty uh and
no real tie to um commercialism
so the interest was getting the truth
out
maybe selling 100 albums um but really
um changing minds more than
having a pop single or getting on mtv
um and the right you know with reagan we
could talk all
all night about uh reagan and central
america but um
really that was uh something that
opened my eyes the punk rock movement
opened my eyes to to
reagan's policies and and really drove
me to actually
visit nicaragua in 1990 i believe
on a small relief mission right after
the war
um but i'm not a latin american expert
so
so i'll just kind of leave it at that
thanks sure um questions
[Music]
humber hi mauricio thank you so much for
your talk
i was wondering there's there's been a
lot of conversation
about like co-creating with communities
and i was
wondering if you like why did you choose
to
like create this um comic with artists
rather than
like commune like immigrant communities
for instance like create
the art with those communities uh
yeah um
well part of it is you know
knowing my skill set and how much time i
i have um i make comics i know
um professional artists and i i
can get into those circles um
and i i really didn't expect to spend
uh the entire year focused on on this
one project
um also i
i there's something about engaging
people that aren't engaged in
that specific topic that's very powerful
um i would love to do a project with
with migrants
um and there were some migrants uh
involved in border acts and
and even someone who is here
uh without a without papers um
but i won't get too much into that um
however
they already know the history they know
what's
happening what's happening to them how
they're seen by society
and so i thought opening it up to
other people um who might not
um you know as jim points out in the
video
uh there are a lot of teams and so you
know for
some of the comics we had up to seven
people working on a comic all looking at
this
topic and all learning from it and
really absorbing it
and if i could create um a few
more advocates for the border crisis
issues uh i i felt that um
it was a good strategy and and
they further you know reached out to
their audiences and and sort of
um got the the word much further than i
could have
done on my own does that make sense
okay yeah thank you thank you
javier
everyone uh mauricio thank you for for
the presentation
for for the project uh my question is
um do you do you see any value in
perhaps
uh offering a translated version of this
anthology to spanish
is it feasible even or have you thought
about it
um yes and uh i've done it so
uh one of the things that i i didn't fit
into the video
is that we had a team of
translators who i i knew one of them
when i
lived in france and he got a large group
in barcelona
to take every single page and translate
it so obviously um
you know or audience is latin american
so
they worked with a few editors i believe
in arizona
and one in mexico to proofread it to
take the um sort of
castilian aspect out and translate into
more universal spanish
um so uh part of those have a few of
those have gone out
um two artists the rest are sitting on
my hard drive until
tomorrow when i have time again to work
on this
and we hope to get a new all spanish
edition
out um i'd like to
try to do another fundraiser or somehow
figure out a way to fund
the printing so we can um get them
into the remain in mexico camps physical
copies
um so we have a few leads uh there's
a nun who's uh doing some incredible
work on the border um
like smuggling reading materials and
things into uh the camps
um and so you know it's it's
an ongoing uh process but it's it's not
complete and
it's kind of time consuming as well to
redo the lettering but
luckily we don't have to redo the art so
it'll be forthcoming
thank you thank you
other questions
um well i'll i'll uh until we have
another question
um i had another question that was more
um about process and that is
um i'm curious to hear about
the the relationship a bit more about
the relationship between
um this project the um
uh the project um i'm forgetting the
name of the the
the woman who was speaking about project
amplify
and the southern texas uh human rights
group um and what what were the
connections between
all three you know you mentioned in the
in the talk that you were already
working on the project before
um connecting with project amplify but
i'm also interested in
the connection with um with the south
texas
human rights group
um it feels like i almost woke up one
morning
you know just thinking uh is anybody
paying attention
and as i explored um
you know just google searches and
whatnot i i
came across project amplify and um i
might think someone might have pointed
me the way and i
reached out to to them and uh
that's when we struck up a sort of
partnership
on part of the book so they
supplied um the verbatim transcripts
that were presented to the supreme court
in flores versus bar
and i sifted through those and um gave
them out to
to artist teams to um illustrate
um and after that they've just been so
supportive uh
warren benford is someone who i can call
at any point
and just ask uh her to try to
you know get the the word out there or
or
other things she was instrumental in
getting uh senator
jeff merkley on board he wrote the the
prologue
to the edition and finally um the south
texas human rights center
um you know i estimated that
this project would make maybe a few
hundred to a few thousand dollars um not
much more
and uh as i was thinking okay so i'll
direct the money to the races like just
days after that they did a facebook post
and raised 12 million dollars
off of a single facebook post
and i just i thought i i don't want to
um
take all this artwork this all these
um hours of work and
raise you know a drop in the ocean i
set out to find a very small very um
lean nonprofit and so i
consulted guidestar and looked for
extremely small budgets and
uh i came across an aclu listing of
underfunded projects doing essential
work on the border
and that's when i i found three
organizations
uh for various reasons two of them just
were like comics um and uh
eddie was just great he was like yeah
gung-ho let's do it
um and also the mission is it's a
difficult one and
i i like problems i guess um it's
hard to convince someone to
fund an organization that provides water
uh for migrants who are crossing the
border but also on forensic recovery
um it's it's difficult to talk about
it's uncomfortable
and you know it's it's hard to pitch so
that attracted me i i wanted a challenge
i wanted
um people to be aware of um what we're
really talking about and it's
life and death and so that's how
i decided on south texas human rights
center
heather you have a question yeah um
i have two questions the the first one
is
you mentioned early on um your decision
to not mention the name of he who must
not be named
um throughout the whole uh work and i
wonder if you could talk more about
why you made that decision and how
important it was to the project
um and um my other
question is uh
less political more just aesthetic um we
saw such an interesting range of styles
and i wonder if you could talk about
just a bit more about the decision to
use all these different um
visual styles uh and and you know one
moment i even noticed the back of
the current president's head and it
looked really like gary trudeau draws
that hair like thing
mongoose sort of device on that person's
head
um so that was a moment where i saw a
direct sort of influence of like oh yeah
i've seen
work that looks like this before and
other things i was like i haven't seen
anything that looked like this you know
it was really unique so i wonder if you
could just talk a little bit about
um the aesthetics uh
the the aesthetics is simple i i just
put the project out there and i
don't know how i got so lucky
um the artwork that came back was just
really top-notch i'm really professional
and the sort of variety that i wanted i
you know early on i considered for about
two seconds doing my own book before i
even thought of doing an anthology and
i thought no it would be one point of
view
it would be one voice and it would be
limited by
my reach my my scope um so i really
wanted to
to do the project in a way that had
multiple
different viewpoint styles approaches
um and points of view so um
that was the aesthetic bit um
not mentioning it um
so uh
that person thrives on
attention and we don't need to
give it any more attention than it gets
with a tweet
um also
i i'm just continuously frustrated so
um i i was going to include this in the
presentation but then
it was just getting too long um for a
little while i was doing
a comic based on
on that person's antics and
i i couldn't keep it up i as soon as i
finished a comic the issue was
irrelevant because it was replaced by
another issue
um you know with firing so if i spent
hours drawing
this one person and a week later they
were out of the administration
um and the same sort of dynamic was
happening
with some of these important issues that
we were losing
the thread on the migrant crisis because
he was doing some other
clown show or you know dragging a pony
and
balancing a ball on his nose and
all these other um ridiculous things
that he does to get attention
um so i i really didn't want
his inclusion in this volume to take
away
any of the energy or attention from
where it should be on
the individuals who are actually
affected by this crisis
and uh we did negotiate that um
that one image that you mentioned i
i think there might be two appearances
in the book and i asked and the artists
were very um polite and accommodating
to not show his face and to not write
his name out
and um and i'm glad for it
no regrets i think he's implicated
enough
by his policies and actions that we
don't need to
name or depict him anymore
uh there's a there's a question from uh
from the chat
um from caitlin um
maurice mauricio thank you for inviting
your saw colleagues to this important
discussion
how have the children whose stories are
amplified in this project
responded to seeing the comics
uh well we don't know um
the all the testimony is anonymous um
for various reasons for uh the
protection of the children
um so so i don't know if any of the
the children in the exhibits um has
actually seen the comic um and that is
what i have
hope to do on later on is try to
find a few agencies that can distribute
uh the
electronic version in the spanish uh
version
um but yeah sadly we just can't get that
sort of feedback
other questions uh a question over here
thank you uh hi mauricio i'm a visitor
to the lecture
uh very impressive work i'm curious to
ask your thought having completed the
work and looking back at it at this
point um
how do you situate the decisions that
you made for one
reason or the other up front to go with
as an independent work
and even thinking at the outset about a
sort of a punk rock perspective if you
will right
governing the aesthetic but what's been
realized now the work you have in front
of you
i'm curious to get your thought about
how you see it having similarity or
dissimilarity to the kind of stuff joe
sacco
has done right years ago curious to hear
your thoughts about that
and how you see sort of the elasticity
of comics to do this kind of work
oh wow joe sacco um
i think that her expected i love his
work i love what he's done
i'm not a journalist i'm not trained in
journalism
i'm not a historian i make comics
so i wouldn't um
it just wouldn't be my my um my
wheelhouse to
to try to do a sort of in-depth
um project on the border
um however i have opinions and i i
have google so so i can't find enough
information
to provide my viewpoint but really
um going back to that punk aesthetic it
was
a very inclusive movement you know um
if you had a band that had been
rehearsing for three weeks
in a basement in you know falls church
or alexandria
you could be on stage with minor threat
or you know um later on fugazi or you
know
so some of the key bands um
so i think this um this inclusive
spirit uh permeated through through the
the border um anthology some of the
artists are actually first-time comic
creators
a lot of the longer pieces i i sort of
ripped
out of the hands of writers who are like
well i've never written a comic before
and i was like no
it'll be okay come on um and so we we
sort of coached them on how to
translate their script into comic book
form
um for example brian delay he
had never done a comic but was really
really enthused by comics so
um see i think by providing a
large platform getting
a lot of different voices and it it just
harkens back to that diy
i'm spirit is it did i answer your
question
that's good thank you thanks maurice
thanks
other questions
i just want to make a comment i think
joe sacko would love this comic
uh joe sacco has a new workout uh titled
paying the land that just came out
uh about a year ago but uh this is very
much uh
mauricio's a cousin uh this is this is
the same
realm and i think these two comic
artists
would be uh very very compat
compatible and yeah
so anyway that's interesting to mention
that because that's also
uh art that has uh
advocacy but it's it's art that
uh is formed uh in a different way but
very very similar uh so anyway it's it's
worth mentioning
that's a nice nice comparison
if anyone has joe sacco's address i'm
happy to send him a copy
so i i have a question mauricio um i
think about sort of
uh having been outraged by the same
things you were outraged
over the years um and one of the things
that
overall i've come to realize is that
how little at least i don't know whether
it was ever ever otherwise but how
little accountability there is over time
in other words no one's paid
no one's paid a penalty for what the
reagan administration did in latin
america no one's paid a penalty for
what's happened in
happened in iraq in the first decade of
this century um
uh any thoughts about
whether we can
whether i mean it's it's critical that
we're
what you're doing what you're doing to
raise awareness of the
the problems is there any thought about
a royal art could have in terms of
actually trying to bring people to
account i guess
um i'm sorry trying to bring people to
bring people to account
for their crimes yeah yeah wow um
you know it's tough yeah with without
getting
mystical and you know karma
or anything like that i
um uh
we recently saw a shepherd fairy
um exhibit in los angeles and
it was wonderful to revisit
um scumbags like nixon and
reagan and all their awfulness
um and so i think
that's part of what artists
who create political art do is they
they preserve the ugliness they don't
look away
they they look straight into that storm
and say you know
we're watching and we're recording it
and um that was one of the goals with
border x is to
try to create something um of quality
that
would endure on past this administration
and hey guess what
in just like what 60 days um
border x will have endured past
this administration and and it remains
an account
of some of the atrocities but to be
clear
um the border migration uh crisis has
been going on
well before um this currently
so um you know there's a lot of
accountability to
spread around there yeah
okay well we're up on 6 30 um
so i just wanted to um
with everyone uh uh thank you so much
for
for your time and and for for the
putting together the presentation
and um and
i look forward to being able to to read
um to read the to read border x
um and actually that's that's a question
and uh to end with how how can we all
get our hands
on uh physical copies of
of border x border x it's
really available through any uh retailer
uh mostly online you know um that's
really stocked on the shelves
but if you go to www.orderhyphenx.com
you can order it through the big players
like amazon and barnes and nobles but
also through eight books
through indie bound through all the
smaller distributors and their links
on the website to the smaller
distributors and the best thing honestly
is just call up your local bookstore and
do like a curbside pickup you know and
just support them they they need it
especially the comic book stores they're
really
taking a hit so um if you're here in
somerville
kamikaze is a wonderful place they've
been very supportive
and yeah support your local merchants
please
all right all right thank you so much
and thank you everyone for joining us
tonight
all right bye